This lecture is about the similarity
based approaches to text for
clustering.
In this lecture, we're going to
continue the discussion of how to do a
text clustering.
In particular, we're going to cover a
different kind of approaches than
generative models.
And that is similarity based
approaches.
So the general idea of similarity based
clustering is to explicitly specify a
similarity function to measure the
similarity between 2:00 text objects.
Now this is in contrast with a
generative model where we implicitly
define the clustering bias.
By using a particular objective
function like a likelihood function.
The whole process is driven by
optimizing the likeable, but here we
explicitly provide a review of what we
think are similar, and this is often
very useful because then it allows us
to inject any particular view of
similarity into the clustering program.
So once we have a similarity function,
we can then aim at optimally
partitioning to partitioning the data
into clusters or into different groups.
Anne, try to maximize the intragroup
similarity and minimize the intergroup
similarity.
That is, to ensure the objects that are
put in the same group to be similar,
but the objects that are put into
different groups to be not similar, and
these are the general goals of
clustering.
And there's often a tradeoff between
achieving both goals.
Now, there are many different methods
for doing similarity based clustering.
In general, I think we can distinguish
two strategies at high level.
One is to progressively construct the
hierarchy of clusters.
And so this often leads to hierarchical
clustering an we can further
distinguishes two ways to construct the
hierarchy depending on whether we
started with the collection to divide
the collection or start with individual
objects and gradually group them
together.
So one is bottom up that can be called
agglomerative, where we gradually Group
A similar object into larger and larger
clusters until we group everything
together.
The other is top down or divisive.
In this case we gradually partitioning
the whole data set into smaller and
smaller clusters.
The other general strategy is to start
with the initial tentative clustering
and then iteratively improve it and
this often leads to a flat clustering.
One example is K means.
So as I just said, there are many
different clustering methods available
and.
A full coverage of all these custom
methods would be beyond the scope of
this course.
But here we can talk about the two
representative methods and.
In some detail.
One is hierarchical agglomerative
clustering or agency, the other is
K-MEANS.
So first let's look at the
agglomerative hierarchical clustering.
In this case, we are giving a
similarity function calls to measure
similarity between two objects and then
we can gradually group similar objects
together in a bottom up profession to
form larger and larger groups, and they
also form a hierarchy and then we can
stop when some stopping criterions
that.
I could be either some number of
classes has been achieved, or the
threshold for similarity has been
reached.
There are different variations here and
there mainly differ in the ways to
computer group similarity based on the
individual object similarity.
So let's illustrate how can induce a
structure based on just similarity.
So start with all the text objects and
we can then measure the similarity
between them.
Of course based on the provider
similarity function and then we can see
which pair has the highest similarity
and then just group them together.
And then was going to see which pair
is.
The next one to group.
Maybe these two now have the highest
similarity.
And then we can gradually group them
together in every time we're going to
pick the highest similarity similarity
pairs to group.
This will give us a binary tree
eventually to group everything
together.
Now depending our applications, we can
use the whole hierarchy as structure
for browsing for example, or we can
choose the cut off at say come here to
get four clusters.
Or we can use the threshold to cut or
we can cut at this high level to get
just the two clusters.
So this is a general idea.
Now, if you think about how to
implement this algorithm, you will
realize that we have everything
specified except for how to compute the
group similarity.
We are only given the similarity
function or two objects, but as we
group groups together we also need to
assess the similarity between two
groups.
And there are also different ways to do
that, and there's the three popular
methods are single link complete link
an average link?
So given two groups and singling
algorithm is going to define the group
similarity as the similarity of the
closest repair of the two groups.
Complete Link defines the similarity of
two groups as the similarity of the
father sister pair.
Average link defines the similarity as
average of similarity of all the pairs
of the two groups.
So it's much easier to understand these
methods by illustrating them.
So here are two groups G1 and G2 with
some objects in each group, and we know
how to compute the similarity between
two objects.
But the question now is, how can we
compute the similarity between the two
groups?
And then we can in general basis on the
similarities of the objects in the two
groups.
So in terms of single link and we're
just looking at the closest pair.
So in this case these two pairs objects
would define the similarity of the two
groups.
As long as they are very close orders,
say the two groups are very.
Close so it's optimistic view of
similarity.
The complete link, on the other hand,
will be in some sense pessimistic and
by taking the similarity of the two
farthest appear as the similarity for
the two groups.
So we're going to make sure that if the
two groups are
having a high similarity, then every
pair of the two the objects in the
group will be insured to have
high similarity.
Every link is in between, so it takes
average of all these pairs.
Now, these different ways of computing
group similarities will need to
different clustering algorithms, and
they will generally give different
results.
Now, so it's useful to take a look at
their differences and to make
comparison.
Our first single link.
Can be expected to generate the loose
clusters.
The reason is becausw.
As long as two objects are very similar
in the two groups, it would bring the
two groups together.
If you think about this is similar to
having parties with people, then it
just means two groups of two groups of
people would be putting together as
long as each group there is a person
that is well connected with the other
group.
So the two leaders of the two groups
can have a good relationship with each
other and then they will bring together
the two groups.
In this case, the cluster is rules
because there's no guarantee that other
members of the two groups are actually
very close to each other.
Sometimes they may be very far away.
Now in this case it's also based on
individual decision, so it could be
sensitive to outliers.
The complete linker is in the opposite
situation where we can expect the
clusters to be tight.
Anne, it's also based on individual
decision, so it can be sensitive to
outliers.
Again, to continue the analogy to
having a party of people then complete
the link would mean when two groups
come together they want to ensure that
even the.
Even the people that are unlikely to
talk to each other would be comfortable
with talking to each other, so ensure
the whole class to be coherent.
The average link, of course is in
between and group decision, so it's
going to be insensitive to outliers.
In practice, which one is the best?
Well, this will depend on the
application and sometimes you need a
loose classes and to aggressively on
cluster objects together.
Then maybe simple English good.
But other times you might need a tight
clusters, then completely completely
better, but in general you have to
empirically evaluate these methods for
your application to know which one is
better.
Now let's look at another example of
method for similarity based classroom
in this case.
Which is called K means clustering will
represent each text object as a term
vector and then assuming similarity
function defined onto objects.
Now we're going to start with some
tentative clustering result by just
selecting Kate randomly selected
vectors as centroids of K clusters and
treat them as sentence as they
represent each cluster.
So this is.
This gives us the initial tentative
classroom.
And then we're going to iteratively
improve it, and the process goes like
this.
And once we have these Central
Eastside, we're going to assign a
vector to the cluster hosts entry that
is closest to the current vector.
So basically we're going to measure the
distance between this vector and each
of the centroids, and see which one is
closest to this one, and then just put
this class this object into that
cluster.
Now this is to have tentative.
Assignment of objects into clusters and
we're going to partition or the objects
into K clusters based on our tentative
clustering centroids.
And then we're going to recovery,
compute the centroid based on the
allocated objects in each cluster.
And this is.
To adjust the centroid and then we had
repeated this process until the
similarity based on objective function.
In this case it's within cluster sum of
squares converges an theoretically we
can show that this process actually is
going to minimize the within cluster
sum of squares where define objective
function.
Given K clusters.
So it can be also shown this process
will converge to a local minimum.
I think about this process for a
moment.
It might remind you the EM algorithm
for mixture model.
Indeed, this algorithm is very similar
to the EM algorithm for the mixture
model for clustering.
So more specifically, we also
initialize these.
Predators in the EM algorithm, so the
random inner inner initialization is
similar.
And then in the EML with them, you may
recall that we're going to repeat
eastep and M step to improved our
primary destinations.
In this case, we're going to improve
the clustering result iteratively by
also doing 2 steps, and in fact the two
steps are very similar to EM algorithm.
In that when we allocate vector into
one of the clusters based on our
tentative clustering, it's very similar
to inferring the distribution that has
been used with generally the document
in the mixture model.
So it's essentially similar to eastep.
Also, what's the difference?
While the differences here, we don't
make a probabilistic on location as in
the case of the step.
But rather we make a choice.
We're going to make a call if this data
point is closest to cluster two that
were going to say you are in class too.
So there's no choice, and we're not
going to say you are 70% belonging to
class too.
And so we're not going to have a
probability, but we're going to just
put one object into precisely one
cluster.
In the E step, however, we do a
probabilistic location, so we split the
counts.
And we're not going to say exactly
which distribution has been used to
generate the data point.
Now the next we're going to adjust the
centroid, and this is very similar to M
step where we re estimate the
parameters.
That's when we'll have a better
estimate of the parameter.
So here we have a better clustering
result by adjusting the centroid.
And note that the central is adjusted
based on the average of the vectors in
the.
A cluster, so this is also similar to
the M step, where we do counts pull
together counter and normalize them, or
the difference of course is also
because of the difference in the
instep, and we're not going to consider
probabilities when we count the points
in this case, for K means we're going
to only count the objects allocated to
this cluster, and this is only a subset
of data points.
But in the EM algorithm, we in
principle consider all the data points.
Based on probabilistic allocations.
But in nature they are very similar and
that's why it's also maximizing where
defined objective function and it's
guaranteed to convert converted local
minimum.
So to summarize our discussion of
clustering methods, we first discussed
the model based approaches, mainly the
mixture model.
And here we use is implicitly
similarity function.
To define the clustering bias, there's
no explicit definer similarity
function.
The model defines clustering bias.
And the clustering structure is built
into a generated model.
That's why we can use potentially a
different model to recover different
instruction.
Complex generative models can be used
to discover complex clustering
structures.
We did not talk about it, but we can
easily design generated model to
generate a hierarchical clusters.
We can also use prior to further
customize clustering algorithm to for
example, control the topic of 1 cluster
or multiple clusters.
However, one disadvantage of this
approach is that there is no easy way
to direct or control the similarity
measure.
Sometimes we want to do that, but it's
very hard to inject the such a explicit
definition of similarity into such a
model.
We also talked about the similarity
based approaches.
These approaches are more flexible.
Directly specify similarity functions.
But one potential disadvantage is that
their object function is not always
very clear.
The K means algorithm has a clearly
defined the objective function, but
it's also very similar to a model based
approach.
The hierarchical clustering algorithm,
on the other hand, is.
It's harder to.
To specify the objective function so
it's not clear what exactly is being
optimized.
Both approaches can and generate the
term clusters and document clusters.
An term clusters can be in general
generated by representing each term
with some text content.
For example, take the context of each
term as a representation of each term
as we have done in paradigmatic
relation learning.
And then we can certainly cluster terms
based on actually their tax
representations.
Of course, term clusters can be
generated by using generative models as
well as we have seen.